foreign
[Music]
figurines
[Applause]
[Music]
fading on the ground for The Hourglass
to break
[Music]
I'm busy wasting time
[Applause]
[Music]
getting off too much
your life is getting hard
living month to month on a credit card
it's never quite enough
[Music]
[Applause]
hi
and it never felt so good
[Music]
thank you
so good
hey friends so I just wanted to thank
Mufasa here for safetying for me there
but fossa is an awesome human being tell
them where they can find you on social
media so you can find me on Instagram
and mostly YouTube these days uh we're
at uh
perfect thanks so much again buddy first
man outstanding
what up friends I hope you enjoyed
watching that video at least as much as
I enjoyed making it I have been
searching for a fire POI sponsor for
years and I am so grateful that fire
Mecca stepped up to the plate uh and
gave me a reason to go out and do some
fireflow this month so thank you so much
to fire Mecca if you'd like to grab a
set of these awesome elite fire POI from
them
um which they have technora tethers as
well as a steel cable that runs down the
length of the tethers as a Fail-Safe
should the Techno fail and of course
they have these awesome Ultra knobs
handles on them for Led handle action
which you know I love if you'd like to
grab a set of these elite fire POI for
yourself you can do so by heading on
order to firemeka.com and using my
special promo code drexfactor at
checkout that gets you a discount on
your own set of fire POI and it helps
out the channel so everybody wins they
also have a line of fire POI that is
specifically geared toward words people
that are just starting out on their fire
Journey so you might want to check that
out as well
uh also I just want to put out a huge
thank you to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling
pyroterra light toys and Ultra Ploy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel That is Lane machinsky and
Becca beckonen thank you both so very
much for supporting me in my mission and
speaking of thank yous this video would
not be possible without the kind support
of all of these lovely people right here
these are my flow patrons over on
patreon they and the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on this channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very very generous support and if you
out there watching are not currently
supporters and you'd like to become
supporters you can become a supporter by
heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and signing up you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards there and even better you'll be
helping me out in my mission to bring
flow Arts employee spinning to the whole
wide world so go check that out please
and thank you
I will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of other fire performance
videos I've done down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you're
watching on YouTube and the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you might like
this top video here based upon your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a look
as well thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon peace